[Music]
this morning on the dish
cooking expert and author jack bishop
he's an original cast member of
america's test kitchen the pbs show that
rethinks recipes from the ground up
it's been on the air for 20 years and
draws more than 2 million
viewers each week and as more of us
spend time in the kitchen during the
pandemic he's hoping to inspire even
novice chefs to make our home-cooked
creations
the best they can be
[Music]
welcome to america's test kitchen a 15
thousand square foot state-of-the-art
facility where more than 50
test cooks taste and test recipes
as you're tasting think about what does
bacon give you it gives you meatiness
it gives you salt jack bishop is the
chief creative officer and
america's taste expert taking viewers
through the cooking process
you want smoke you want spice you want
tomato and you want sweetness
all of that was before covet 19. welcome
to america's test kitchen at home
at home at home this is atk
the pandemic edition i want you to learn
one thing buy the real deal from greece
everybody was working from home
developing recipes we figured out how to
do
like recipe tastings over zoom does that
work
it looks great surprise
surprise normally we have about 30
people on the crew
and what's normally a three-week shoot
was a 10-week shoot
wow yeah it was actually kind of fun we
looked at it rather than a deficit
saying we can't be in our amazing
studios with you know
hair and makeup and wardrobe we're going
to be at home and it's going to be
in our kitchens and it's going to be
more real oh this is like magic
happening in the kitchen right now the
job of empowering home
cooks to thrive more than they fail
continues these are delicious
my life's work and work at america's
test kitchen is always about home
cooking
so i'm pretty much the only person on
staff who never went to culinary school
so i know what it's like to like have
sort of mediocre knife skills uh
you know and like this recipe is way too
hard people at home can't do that like i
feel like i'm a teacher that's what i do
and what i'm trying to do is give people
the tools to be successful in the
kitchen first of all to inspire them so
what are we doing here on this day
i got to be the student i'm going to
teach you how to taste
olive oil like an expert oh really the
goal here is to break the oil into
little teeny droplets and
aspirate it across your palate and the
roof of your mouth so let me show you
it's very elegant
okay your turn
how much am i supposed to have in there
whatever's in there is going down
bishop's fun-loving familiarity with
food began
at age 12 when his mom drafted him to be
the family's chief cook
while she worked long late hours my mom
would call
from work every day around 4 30 and
start to talk me over the phone through
the recipe i mean you know remember this
is the old days
in a couple months i figured it all out
and all i wanted to do was be in the
kitchen
smelling talking and you know just
absorbing everything
oh what an amazing tale it's the joy of
cooking i mean really i love
i just i love it did you realize this
was
a career for you oh never you know i
went off to college i was an english
major
i thought i would be an editor a
journalist a writer
but i never really thought about cooking
as something
that would be work it always was
pleasure
perfect timing and it still is
on the pit outside his north fork long
island home
you want me to do the rest he and his
wife have been sharing the domestic
duties
and loving every minute our adult
daughters would say
that we hog the kitchen and we keep them
out you know we've been
cooking together for more than 30 years
and it's just part of our lives
and we love to entertain entertain and
travel like so many of us their family
vacation
to madrid was canceled so they decided
to bring a little bit
of it to the dish tell me what's on this
fabulous table
this is a spanish menu we've got paella
with local clams from peconic bay here
on long island
chicken chorizo shrimp and so we've got
hummus with smoked paprika which is my
favorite spice
some local vegetables would you like
some flour i would love some flan
oh wow look at that it's got a little
bit of orange and cardamom
i'm gonna have to get you a little extra
you need the caramel i made you caramel
so i appreciate it
it gets better with every bite i'm not
kidding thank you
really we didn't get to go to spain this
year but
you can make the food at home and i
think that's one of the great things
about food is it takes you wherever you
want to go
it's meals like this that bishop hopes
will inspire people
to use america's test kitchen recipes as
a passport to travel
on a culinary adventure do you think you
know a lot of people have been cooking
in the pandemic do you think they'll
continue once we're out of this
folks have discovered cooking and are
enjoying cooking and i think we're going
to look back
three years from now five years from now
at oh
the pandemic one of the good lasting
things was that people learned the
kitchen's not that scary
it's actually fun to cook and that
they're going to continue to do that
cheers cheers
and mama miller did not come
empty-handed
i brought the flan we have jack bishop
and marie haycox our very own
starving right now and taste i have to
know because i ate two slices of this in
one sitting
oh delicious it was really good oh
really good i love the orange
yeah that's great is it a great
possession yeah
like it's not really caramel but it's
delicious tastes like it
why didn't we get to do the olive oil i
think jeff would have been really good
[Laughter]
what you said it was like it was did you
not know you needed to swallow was that
what you were
either trying to gargle it at the same
time i don't know what was it
gargle it was like how much do you get
in
how much did you get in like how much do
you sip did it taste better i don't know
i mean i
this is something that you can explain
to us possibly she'll explain why
after the show we could post the whole
ig story about it i like that here's a
look at
stop talking about this but we don't
want to stop talking